threw up during the finale of we belong
together
on the other day I asked y'all to send
in your like most memorable experiences
at concerts so and I would ask you to
use the hashtag Kelly concerts and so my
team has gathered this info for me I
have yet to see it so I'm going to read
them aloud for the very first time your
most amazing experience as a concerts
slightly scared but it's gonna be fun
but I'm still slightly scared
2004 American Idol live tour oh no I was
ten did karaoke wearing a classic
oversized concert tee that I tied at the
bottom with a hair elastic I used to do
that and was sporting a gorgeous local
oniel style bun they gave out free
pop-tarts after the show and I ended up
Oh
I ended up puking in my Nana's kitchen
sink concert was still a 10 out of 10
now really sorry Kat O'Connor that's
awesome
[Music]
at planting our happy place oh I like
this person my parents took my sister
need to see Neil Diamond very cool I was
probably six or seven when he sang song
song blue is that a real song song blue
maybe it's a typo if it's not someone
was high high a lot
[Laughter]
song song blue it's awesome you know
what if it's a real song I'm gonna cover
it song sung blue this was wrong I'm
sorry Neil Diamond I got upset because
he left out the part from the album that
went the chickens can sing it the frogs
can sing it I stood on my seat and
yelled you sang it wrong
my mom was mortified and pretty much
stuck me back at D Marquis Oh Pearl Jam
my dad pulled me out of school I had no
cool dad taking you to Pearl Jam
I wouldn't allowed to listen to secular
music okay I had no idea when he did
though huh oh you're welcome mom I had
no idea when he was signing me out he
put two words in as the reason for
leaving early Pearl Jam the nurse
thought it was some kind of new flu
strand we just left nurse is super hip
my first concert was Cher what that's
amazing she made her big entrance on a
giant chandelier as you would my mom not
wanting me to expect the same from
everyone turned to me and said now not
all concerts are like this she letting
you down easy because the next concert
went to is just like someone standing
there awesome
[Music]
where I carry on the emancipation of
Meeny tour with my mom that must have
been cool I was nine and had too many
mozzarella sticks to eat before the show
threw up during the finale of we belong
together which is my mom's favorite so
he had to leave early I'm 22 now and she
still hasn't forgiven me my bad oh my
god gluttony get you every time
[Music]
my first concert was when I was 8 and my
dad took my brother and I to see
meatloaf I would do anything oh my gosh
I love him it was great although I
didn't know the true meaning of most of
the lyrics my dad got so many bad looks
that night especially meatloaf meatloaf
took out a pack of what two two by two
condoms and I kept asking two foot by
two foot condoms is that what that is
implying condoms and I kept asking him
very loudly what is he holding up dad
what is that you man you trying to be
bragging you don't need no two foot
condoms
keep it real I don't care if you are
from Texas brother you lying you're
lying
what can you even do with that let's not
go there okay my first concert was 38
special with iron my first concert was
38 special with Iron Maiden and
point-blank wasn't that a movie break oh
that's right the surfers are so good did
they rob things or they were okay it was
my first date and he pulled up driving
his new used purse I mean this is like a
Dateline special before it existed if
some fool pulls up in a hearse and
expects my behind to get in it I roll it
in that until I'm dead brother I ain't
what defy you
that's gross
yes I love these two Michael Bolton I
don't care what you say the mother can
sing everybody makes fun of me but he
will sing circles around your laughing
behind Oh Tom love and tenderness said I
loved you but I'm life it was so good
but Michael Bolton was Celine Dion as
the okuu assault in Vegas recently and
she was crazy like she's the best
vocalist I've ever heard live ever what
it's insane she's got like four sets of
lungs I was three or four and came down
with a fever during the concert but my
dad refused to leave because he was
obsessed with M be with Michael Bolton
your dad it's wrong that's wrong so
we've learned here today that it's Point
Blank not Point Break is abandoned and
that people into really cool concerts
that I didn't get to go to
and while the vomiting and as lead our
kids they weren't drinking like weird
all right bye e I will not stop talking
until you subscribe to my youtube
channel that's right and I could talk a
lot seriously not gonna stop yep still
here not going anywhere I see you don't
walk away from this